Comment ça tu t'es perdu Stéphane ? Mais enfin,  je sais pas,  qu'est ce qu'il y a autour de toi ?
Ben je ne sais, pas, je ne comprends pas, il y a des bureaux mais pas de studio !
Hou hou ! Bon,  je crois qu'on va
l'envoyer faire un petit stage chez les fourmis du désert.
Des chercheurs de
Toulouse étudient les fourmis du désert
depuis plusieurs années maintenant et
particulièrement les espèces
Cathaglyphis fortis et Mélophorus
Bagoti, qui sont très douées pour
s'orienter, plus que Stéphane en tout cas.
Ces fourmis aux grandes jambes se
déplacent extrêmement vite, près d'un
mètre par seconde, ce qui ne facilite pas leur étude.
D'autant plus qu'elles vivent dans le désert et
comme elles ne sont pas du
tout agressives,  elle préfèrent sortir
chercher de quoi se nourrir quand la
température du sol dépasse les 50 degrés
histoire d'être sûres de ne trouver personne... à
part des chercheurs particulièrement
déterminés et résistants à la chaleur. Au
beau milieu du sahara ou de la steppe
australienne ces fourmis partent
individuellement à la recherche de
nourriture et elles retrouvent le chemin de
leur fourmilière sans marquer leur
passage avec des phéromones,
contrairement à beaucoup d'autres
espèces que l'on retrouve dans nos
jardins.
Les chercheurs ont alors montré qu'elles
se servaient principalement de la mémoire
visuelle de leur environnement ce que
devrait apprendre Stéphane.
Lors de ses déplacements,  la fourmi regarde
régulièrement autour d'elle,  elle scanne
son environnement en particulier
lorsqu'elles ne le connait pas
et au ralenti ça donne ça :
Dans une première expérience,  les
chercheurs ont disposé de grands repères
visuels sur le chemin entre la
fourmilière et une source de nourriture.
A partir de ce que l'on connaît du champ
de vision des fourmis,  les chercheurs ont
même reconstitué ce que la fourmi
pourrait voir dans ces conditions.
Ca vous paraît pas fou-fou comme vision,
et pourtant c'est comme ça que les
fourmis retrouvent leur chemin, et très
rapidement,  elles sont donc induites en
erreur si les chercheurs cachent ou déplacent une partie des repères visuels.
Mais les chercheurs sont allés plus loin,
et ils ont montré que les fourmis
pouvaient apprendre de leurs mauvaises
expériences et adapter leur trajet pour
éviter les obstacles qu'elles ont déjà
rencontré. Pour cela,  les scientifiques
ont créé dans un coin de steppe
australienne un véritable parcours pour fourmis.
A partir de leur nid,  ici entouré d'un
seau rouge,  les fourmis ne peuvent aller
que sur un grand pont aux parois glissantes, ici en blanc
qui les amène droit au seau
blanc dans lequel se trouve la nourriture.
Et pas n'importe quelle
nourriture... des morceaux de cookies !
Reprenons le chemin des fourmis : au bout du pont, elles se retrouvent 10 cm au dessus
du seau de cookies et peuvent donc se
laisser tomber ou sauter.
Les fourmis n'ont qu'un sens de circulation
possible et peuvent s'entraîner à faire
des allers-retours sans intervention
humaine. Mais sur leur trajet de retour
les chercheurs ont mis un puits enterré
aux parois lisses : un véritable piège
qu'elles ne découvrent qu'au dernier moment,
et duquel elles ne peuvent ressortir que
par une planche inclinée qu'elles
trouveront plus loin après avoir
traversé une forêt de brindilles qui les
empêchent de courir.
En tombant dans le puits, le trajet des fourmis est donc
considérablement ralenti et cet
événement est mémorisé comme une
expérience très négative.
Les chercheurs observent alors que dés
le 2ème trajet,  la plupart des fourmis
s'arrêtent à l'approche du puits pour
scruter l'environnement,  avant de virer de
bord pour le contourner ou d'y tomber,
mais plus près de la planche qui permet
d'en ressortir. Et plus elles font le trajet,
plus le retour à la fourmilière est efficace.
L'expérience montre que les fourmis se
souviennent et reconnaissent
visuellement l'environnement dans lequel
elles se trouvaient juste avant la chute
et ses souvenirs visuels sont associés
dans leur mémoire à une expérience
négative, qu'elles cherchent ensuite à éviter.
Cette étude établit donc que la mémoire des
fourmis est capable d'intégrer des images de façon
chronologique,  au moins sur quelques
secondes,  et d'y associer après coup un
caractère repoussant. Un mécanisme qui se
révèle particulièrement efficace pour
optimiser les trajets,  et la similarité
des cerveaux à travers toutes les
espèces d'insectes laisse penser aux
chercheurs que ce talent pourrait être
partagé par d'autres,  comme les abeilles
ou les mouches.
Voilà,  la prochaine étape pour les
scientifiques qui fourmillent d'idées
nouvelles est d'intégrer ces résultats à
leur modèle du système nerveux des
insectes pour dévoiler d'autres facultés fourmidables.
Et si tu as aimé ce fourmidable parcours, abonne toi !